what does it mean to exist i've heard
you say that abstractions don't exist
that numbers don't exist
that they're simply stories now here's
the way that i think about that
i can understand that let's say harry
potter to me the story
exists the characters don't but the
story exists
so first of all what does it mean to
exist and what do you mean when you say
that the abstractions themselves don't
exist
in different situations when i'm talking
to different audiences i may articulate
my
my words in a different way so to appeal
to the particular assumptions of that
audience
when i say that abstractions don't exist
i'm appealing to the correspondence
theory of truth which says that mental
states
are only true if they correspond to
non-mental objective states
out there in the world beyond your own
mind
so based on that theory i would say
abstractions don't
exist as far as we can know because they
only exist
as our own mental states they do not
have
necessarily a corresponding state beyond
our own mentation or beyond mentation in
general
so in that sense abstractions are just
that they are
abstractions they do not correspond to
an objective state of affairs outside
mind
now of course the abstractions exist as
such
they exist as abstractions but
most people today they take the
abstractions
further they will say well the
abstractions exist not only as
abstractions
but they correspond to something that is
not itself an abstraction
and that's where i would say what reason
do you have
to believe that theorizing
in science is useful as a predictive
tool
the the elements of our theories like
elemental subatomic particles we have
never seen a higgs boson for instance
we haven't even measured one what we
measure are the results of the decay of
the higgs boson and higgs boson exists
for too short a time
to interact with any measurement
instrument but we talk about the higgs
boson as if it existed why
because nature functions as though it
existed
and that's enough for you to predict
nature's behavior and develop technology
you don't need any more than convenient
fictions
that prove to be predictive in practice
in order to develop technology and prove
the power of science to come up with
explanations
uh forward explanations and retroactive
explanations but we cannot lose from
sight
that these are stories that happen to
have predictive power
nature behaves as though the hicks
existed as though
quantum feuds existed which are pure
abstractions pure theoretical
abstractions
but when we take the philosophical this
is no longer scientific step when we
take the philosophical step to say
this theory is literally what nature
is and when you talk about being about
business now you are in metaphysics
territory
science makes no statements about what
things are science only
says how things behave not what they are
when you take the theory and you say
nature
is that is a higgs boson is a quantum
field
now you are taking a philosophical step
which may but
may not be correct and which science in
any case
cannot either prove or disprove because
it only makes statements about behavior
so i caution against this runway show of
abstraction
that we're engaged in today we take
these useful fictions of scientific
theory which we should take very
seriously because they are very useful
we take them to be literally what is and
there we can go
terribly and drastically wrong